DEAL WITH HIM.
WHERE HE'S ALWAYS FELT THE MOST
COMFORTABLE.
BRIAN TODD, CNN, WASHINGTON.
>>> SO WHAT DOES IT MEAN THAT
THE SEARCH OF MAR-A-LAGO FOUND
DOZENS OF EMPTY FILE FOLDERS?
THE INVENTORY OF WHAT FBI AGENTS
SEIZED THERE SHOWS A CHAOTIC
TANGLE OF MISHANDLED MATERIAL.
IT ALSO LEAVES A LOT OF
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS.
JOINING ME TO TALK ABOUT ALL OF
THIS, JOHN DEAN, FORMER NIXON
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL.
JOHN, IT'S WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU
ON THIS SATURDAY NIGHT.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
I'D LIKE TO START FIRST WITH
WHAT THE TRUMP LAWYERS, HOW THEY
DESCRIBED THIS CONFLICT OVER
THESE DOCUMENTS.
THEY DESCRIBED IT AS SIMILAR TO
A DISPUTE OVER QUOTE, AN OVERDUE
LIBRARY BOOK.
JUST VERY CASUALLY.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THAT
DESCRIPTION?
>> WHEN I FIRST HEARD THAT, I
THOUGHT WELL, WHERE WOULD HE GET
THE LIBRARY CARD?
HE GOT THE LIBRARY CARD, IF THAT
ANALOGY WORKS, AND IT DOESN'T,
FROM THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HE DOESN'T NEED CLARENCE TO GET
TOP SECRET INFORMATION.
BUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TOOK
AWAY THAT CARD LAST NOVEMBER AND
TOLD HIM TO GET EVERYTHING HE'S
BORROWED UNDER THAT CARD BY THE
TIME HE LEAVES SO HE KNEW THAT
WELL IN ADVANCE.
THE OTHER PROBLEM WITH IT REALLY
DOESN'T WORK IS LIBRARY BOOKS DO
NOT CONTAIN THE NATION'S TOP
SECRETS.
AND AN ELABORATE SYSTEM AROUND
THEM TO PROTECT THOSE SECRETS.
A SYSTEM AND A PROCESS THAT HE
JUST TOTALLY CHOSE TO IGNORE.
SO IT JUST DOESN'T WORK.
IT'S LIKE CALLING THE ARGUMENT
THAT WAS MADE BY THAT LAWYER THE
EQUIVALENT OF A CLARENCE DARROW
ARGUMENT.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF FEDERAL
INVESTIGATORS FINDING THESE
DOZENS OF EMPTY FOLDERS MARKED
AS CLASSIFIED AND MORE MUNDANE
ITEMS LIKE NEWS CLIPPINGS.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF WHAT THEY
FOUND AND HOW THEY KIND OF FOUND
THIS MIXTURE OF INFORMATION
TOGETHER?
>> THE INTERMINGLING OF MATERIAL
WAS CERTAINLY COVERED UNDER THE
WARRANT THEY WERE SEARCHING
UNDER BECAUSE IT'S WANTED TO
KNOW WHERE THE MATERIAL WAS
LOCATED.
IF IT WAS CLASSIFIED MATERIAL OR
NATIONAL DEFENSE INFORMATION.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THEY
FOUND.
THEY FOUND CLOTHING.
THEY FOUND HIS PASSPORTS IN HIS
DESK DRAWER.
SO THE EMPTY FOLDERS DON'T TELL
ME A LOT BECAUSE MR. TRUMP WAS
ALWAYS SO CHAOTIC AND
DISORGANIZED THAT I DON'T THINK
HE HAD EVER GET ANYTHING BACK IN
THE RIGHT FOLDER SO THIS IS JUST
NOT SURPRISING.
IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
THEY'RE MISSING OR THEY HAVE
BEEN SOMEHOW TAKEN OUT.
AND I'M SURE THE FBI IS NOW
GETTING THEM ALL BACK IN ORDER.
MOST OF THESE DOCUMENTS,
JESSICA, ARE WELL INDEXED SO
THEY KNOW WHAT HE HAD, WHEN HE
HAD IT, AND THEY CAN PROBABLY
GET IT BACK IN THE RIGHT FOLDER.
>> AND NOW HOW TO ORGANIZE IT
BACK.
ON FRIDAY, WE HEARD FROM TRUMP'S
OWN APPOINTED ATTORNEY GENERAL,
BILL BARR, AND HE SAID THAT THE
DEMAND FOR A SPECIAL MASTER IS A
RED HERRING IN ALL THIS.
HE WENT ON.
WE'VE GOT THAT CLIP.
>> THE DRIVER ON THIS FROM THE
BEGINNING WAS YOU KNOW, LOADS OF
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION SITTING
IN MAR-A-LAGO.
PEOPLE SAY THIS WAS
UNPRECEDENTED.
WELL, IT'S ALSO UNPRECEDENTED
FOR A PRESIDENT TO TAKE ALL THIS
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION AND PUT
THEM IN A COUNTRY CLUB, OKAY?
AND HOW LONG IS THE GOVERNMENT
GOING TO TRY TO GET THAT BACK?
THEY JAWBONED FOR A YEAR.
THEY WERE DECEIVED ON THE
VOLUNTARY ACTIONS TAKEN.
THEY THEN WENT AND GOT A
SUBPOENA.
THEY WERE DECEIVED ON THAT.
THEY FEEL.
AND THE FACTS ARE STARTING TO
SHOW THAT THEY WERE BEING JERKED
AROUND.
>> AND AGAIN, POINTING OUT THAT
WAS FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S OWN
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
JOHN, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF HIS
COMMENTS AND WHAT DO YOU THINK
THE VIEWERS SHOULD BE TAKING
AWAY FROM WHAT THEY'RE HEARING
FROM HIM?
>> I THINK THAT BILL BARR GAVE A
VERY BLUNT SUMMARY OF THE LAW
AND THE SITUATION.
HE'S RIGHT ON.
THESE ARE NOT TRUMP'S DOCUMENTS
TO TAKE ANYWHERE.
THEY WERE THE GOVERNMENT'S.
AND THE WHOLE IDEA OF A SPECIAL
MASTER IS JUST TRYING TO STIR UP
TROUBLE AND DELAY AND CONFUSION
AND HOPEFULLY THE JUDGE WHO
PROBABLY WOULD RESPECT BARR, SHE
MAY HAVE BEEN PROCESSED BY
BARR'S DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE,
HEARS WHAT THE FORMER ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAD TO SAY BECAUSE HE'S
ACTUALLY JUST BLUNTLY STATING
THE LAW AND THE FACTS.
AND THAT, I DON'T THINK IT
SHOULD BE ELEVATED TO ANYTHING
OTHER THAN WHAT HE SAID.
>> AND BEFORE WE LET YOU GO,
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HOW
UNPRECEDENTED THIS IS.
HOW OBVIOUSLY LIVED THROUGH A
KEY FIGURE IN WATERGATE, ALSO A
TIME THAT WAS UNPRECEDENTED.
IF YOU CAN JUST ZOOM OUT FOR A
SECOND AND GIVE PEOPLE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON WHAT WE'RE SEEING.
YOU KNOW, THE VIEW FROM UP TOP
KIND OF PULLING BACK OUT, AND
JUST MAKE SENSE OF WHAT WE'RE
SEEING RIGHT NOW AND HOW
SIGNIFICANT IT IS.
>> YEAH, I ACTUALLY HAD ABOVE
TOP SECRET CLEARANCE AND I CAN
REMEMBER WHEN THE AGENTS CAME TO
ME AND MY SECRETARY AND GAVE US
OUR BRIEFING BEFORE WE COULD GET
THAT HIRED CLARENCE ABOUT TOP
SECRET.
THE POINT THEY WANTED TO MAKE IS
WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH SOME OF
THIS INTELLIGENCE, YOU'VE GOT TO
REMEMBER THAT IT'S HUMAN SOURCES
THAT ARE INVOLVED AND WHILE
YOU'RE READING THE DOCUMENT
ISN'T GOING TO TELL YOU THE NAME
OF THAT SOURCE, THE FACT THAT
THAT MATERIAL IS IN THAT
DOCUMENT, A SOPHISTICATED
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE PERSON CAN
TELL YOU WHERE IT COMES FROM AND
HOW THEY GOT IT.
THEY TOLD US IT'S NOT ONLY TRUE
WITH HUMAN SOURCES, BUT WE HAVE
ELECTRONIC SOURCES.
THIS IS BACK 50 YEARS AGO.
IT'S ONLY GOTTEN MORE
SOPHISTICATED AND THEY USE
EVERYTHING FROM SATELLITES TO
LASER BEAMS TO ALL KINDS OF
THINGS NOW THAT MAKE THESE MUCH
MORE SENSITIVE BECAUSE WE HAVE
CAPABILITIES THAT OUR ENEMIES
DON'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT.
THEY SAID THIS IS VERY PRECIOUS
MATERIAL.
IT COULD COST LIVES.
IT COULD COST BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IF IT GETS RELEASED AND
THEREFORE, YOU'D HAVE TO FOLLOW
A LAID OUT PROCESS AND YOU CAN
DO THIS AND THAT WITH THE
DOCUMENTS.
YOU CAN'T DO THIS AND THAT AND
THE OTHER WITH THEM.
SO I WAS ALWAYS IMPRESSED WITH
THE WHOLE SYSTEM.
THIS WAS, THE SECRET SERVICE AT
THE NIXON WHITE HOUSE USED TO GO
THROUGH THE WHITE HOUSE AT NIGHT
AND LOOK FOR ANY SECRET, ANY TOP
SECRET OR SECRET OR CONFIDENTIAL
MATERIAL THAT WAS LYING ON
ANYBODY'S DESK AND THEY CAME TO
MY OFFICE AND SAID LISTEN, THIS
WAS OUT.
WE WANT TO RETURN IT TO THE THE
PERSON.
HERE'S WHERE IT CAME FROM AND
WE'D LIKE YOU TO GIVE THEM A
LITTLE TALK.
SO IT WAS SORT OF POLICED
INTERNALLY IN THAT ERA.
I SUSPECT THAT FOLLOWED IN LATER
PRESIDENCIES.
SO TRUMP JUST SO IGNORING THE
RULES THAT IT IS BLATANT AND
WHEN OTHER PEOPLE IGNORE THE
RULES AS HE HAS, THEY'VE PAID
CONSEQUENCE.
THEY HAVE GONE TO JAIL FOR THIS.
REALITY WINTER WHO DECIDED TO
LEAK ONE PAGE SPENT FOUR YEARS
IN JAIL.
GENERAL PETRAEUS, WHO WANTED TO
COLLECT INFORMATION FOR
CONVENIENCE IN A BLACK BOOK
FOUND HIMSELF REALLY
DISQUALIFIED AS A FUTURE
PRESIDENT BECAUSE OF THE WAY HE
HANDLED CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
SO THIS IS VERY SERIOUS AND
TRUMP WANTS TO TREAT IT AS AN
OVERDUE LIBRARY BOOK TO MAKE HIS
FOLLOWERS THINK IT'S A LITTLE
DEAL.
IN FACT, IT'